[Music]
okay this is very exciting
we are getting a sneak peek at one of
the most highly anticipated video games
of the season Assassin's Creed unity
takes place during the French Revolution
and it's by the company Ubisoft Ubisoft
is what my wife said to me on my wedding
night helping me once again Erin Blair
hello sir
yeah a little bit of backstory
Assassin's Creed follows this
centuries-old secret war between two
factions the assassins and the Templars
okay in the previous games you play a
person in the present-day
who's related to the lineage of
assassins and using this device called
the animus you go back into your DNA
into your ants and you could play
memories of your ancestors okay so let's
just say we are going to go into the
French Revolution and we are assassins
yeah okay sir
so we play a guy named Arno Dorian on ax
so that's the young Arno and he's being
brought to Versailles this is gorgeous
looking our dad got murdered we were 8
Arno Dorian yes father dead yes then
what he's adopted
then his adoptive father gets killed
although I got some advice for anyone
who wants to adopt Arno Dorian don't do
it kids bad news
I will return when this hand reaches the
top
unless of course unkilled then I'll
never be back yes Father
I'll live in France but I'll have a
British accent I've seen this houses
were Kanye West webs
that's lys she figures into the story a
little bit later I bet you when they
both get older they do it well she ends
up being your sister by adoption by
adoption ok follow yeah so just go
forward here oh is this her yes and you
can't feel one steal what it's an apple
you're stealing an apple oh this is to
steal an apple there we go
I never got a runaway out there with the
latest for the latest go to the white so
I told my grandfather wasn't sick well
so far we've stolen an apple and run in
circles yeah where do we graduate to a
level where I can really excel
let's just skip there now we've been
thrown in the Bastille this is years
later so everyone here is stolen a
different fruits what are you in for not
having a French accent game that's for
watch my father gave it to me let's go
to sleep so to sleep yeah so we've
stolen an apple yeah we've been put in
jail and now it's time to go - yes the
game gets dramatically more exciting you
think he could you just woke up yeah
where'd you kill boy this fist bump
you called me piss pot I'm in no mood
for this what's your name boy oh no oh
no Victor Dorian Dorian Dorian yes your
father's the dead guy that father's the
other dead guy I remember you here's
your watch two months later he's been
training us now okay okay what the we're
trying to escape the Bastille okay let's
get out of here alright so I'm gonna
kill these guys nice I kind of kissed
him
this is fantastic run to the left no run
to the left well I just wanted to get
more free okay nice office
yeah look at that oh yeah that painting
my guys is gonna look at that for a bit
I like women that's a beautiful painting
that's gonna see if I can memorize it
later on
hey get out of here now yeah let's just
keep the best yeah what are you waiting
for Pitt spot why does it keep calling
me because that's just rude at this
point we've trained together for months
in the Bastille he knows my name he
knows I've lost both of my dads
I just saved his life you could pluck
your head out of your own arse arse
they're French
you're French I gotta go right yeah
we're gonna do that's beautiful now that
was just to get to the beginning of the
game just so we're clear
I've been here for six days look at the
map here that's all the things you can
do yeah that's mind-numbing there's
historical figures in this game which is
very excited to find a historical figure
let's find Marat got killed in a bathtub
oh yeah and France if you take a bath
they get mad now in the jump - no - Dom
look at that yeah that is gorgeous
you know what that is you think that's
fog that's actually the odor of the
French people walking up
that is pure frenchman funk rising out
one cool thing about this game is we can
customize what we look like okay let's
get them really colorful yeah I like
that go out the yellow we can jump into
the hey and then mix it up down below
what do you wait no what's that one
yelling about it's the French Revolution
so there i oh you know what this is what
french are like now they're gonna be
airport and they're all yelling so we do
not wish to pay taxes we want everything
for songs all the time we want termini
to pay for our health care i want to
fight somebody kill the criminal let's
go over there protect exactly yeah
process oh no it's nice double
assassination there's no time for that I
hate high-fiving we'd also Ruth the body
should you stand over the body oh I can
loot the body Hobie that's fantastic
she's got an invoice
he got an invoice I got any invoice what
good is an invoice oh let's move the
body again go back go see if we can find
another receipt
excuse me just gonna molest these body
you want to do a mission yeah let's
accomplish something that's our mission
we're gonna stop the public sensors from
suppressing theatrical productions and
you get to kill them or is it just
talking to them and then there's also a
huge assassination question we can do as
well now why would we do that when we
can collect receipts and getting
involved in theatrical labor disputes
let's suppose somebody okay let's kill a
lot of people and take their fruit
where's he gonna die now we're gonna
jump into the hey no one notices that I
just took a 600-foot died in a head what
is it this guy instead of being an
assassin just rent himself out is the
great hey die now I'm just randomly
killing people for murder yeah there's a
hay wagon
note to self jump in to that later on
nice really good at this it's on I love
this Assassin's Creed unity I love the
graphics
I love the violence the realistic
depiction the amount of history in here
is absolutely incredible when the true
spirit of French spoken with a British
accent I'll give this a Bellamy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you